she is therefore promoted in the United
States Army to the grade of lieutenant
colonel
my name is Maria Cal and I am a second
year PhD student in the political
science department here at Yale
University I'm also an active duty Army
Aviation officer
we commemorated my promotion from the
rank of major to lieutenant colonel
it was incredibly humbling there was a
lot of discussion of my professional
career and my accomplishments
but really I wanted to be able to have
an occasion to thank all of those who
supported me throughout the last 17
years of my career I chose to hold it
here in beinecke Plaza because of the
significance of the military memorials
both outside here in vainiki Plaza but
also inside Woolsey Hall it is really
nice to have all these people who mean
so much to me here to celebrate with
them